For this question you're asked to modify the compute ranks code
in order to take into consideration whether links are reciprocal or not.
What we want to know is is a - c a reciprocal link?
It's a reciprocal link if there is a path from c back to a of at most length k
where k is a number that's given to us.
If there is a path back then we won't include a in the calculation for c's rank.
I'm going to look at values of k-- k = 0.
I'm going to ask is a - c reciprocal?
Then from that I'll be able to tell whether to include a or not in the calculation of c's rank.
This is the link we're looking at.
If k = 0 the only links that are excluded are the self links--link to the page itself.
So a - c is not reciprocal in this case, and we should include a in c's calculation.
If k = 1, we're looking to see if there is a direct link back from c to a, and there isn't.
So a - c is not reciprocal and we should include a.
If k = 2, we need to see if there's a path of length 2 from c to a.
If we start at c, then we can only get to d.
That's just one of the two links we're allowed to click on to get back to a.
What we want to know now is can we click on one link from d to get back to a?
The answer is no. We can't, which means that a - c is not reciprocal. We should include a.
If k = 3, we're going to do the same again. We start at c.
We go to d, using up one link.
Then we want to know if by using two clicks we can get back from d to a.
Let's have a look at that. From d we can get to b.
Then that uses up one link, and then can we get to a with one more link?
Yes, we can, because there is a direct link from b to a,
which means that a - c is reciprocal and we should not include a.
If k >= 3, then there is definitely a path of length at least three in there,
which means we should not include a for any values of k >= 3.
Now we're going to code that.
We're going to code a procedure to check whether a - c is reciprocal,
and then we're going to edit the code and compute ranks to take that into consideration.
This is the supplied code.
I'm going to change it to include a second input k.
Then we want to know whether we have that reciprocal link or not. We include the page.
If we don't have a reciprocal link in the graph,
we're going to include node in the calculation if the link node to page is not reciprocal.
I just need to adjust the spacing here, and that's all the change that we need to do to compute ranks.
To code it's reciprocal link, I'm going to use recursion.
If k is 0--that was the first case we looked at in the example--
then we have a reciprocal link whenever the destination and the source are the same.
In that case, I'll return true and otherwise we return false.
If k is not equal to 0, then it's at least 1, which means if there is a direct link
from the destination to the source, then there is most definitely a reciprocal link.
If that's not the case, we're going to look at every node that is linked to from destination.
We're going to check if there is a path of links from that node to the source of length k - 1.
We're already used one step going from destination to node.
That leaves us with k - 1 steps left.
If there is a path--in other words, if reciprocal link graphs in the same graph--
we've got the same source.
We've got our new node, which is hopefully one step closer to the destination.
If that's true, then we're going to return true.
If there is no node for which that's true, we're going to return false.
That completes the procedure.